let's go next to our caller from the 971
area code caller from 971 who's this hey
David can you hear me yeah I can hey I'm
a fan of yours I'm from Oregon great
your audio level is going up and down
like crazy so if you can do something to
just even it out that would be really
great all right can you hear me better
yeah what I'm curious what did you do
that we can just all of a sudden hear
you so well well I wasn't I wasn't on
speaker or audio anything I just had
like earbuds in and I just spoke into
the phone but anyway I was calling just
to wonder I was just wondering if you
had like it's the old man for
supply-side economics I watched a video
of yours I mean I watch a lot of videos
of yours but I watched a video of yours
a little while ago about how supply-side
economics kind of a it's a bad kind of
argument or ideology because listen if
I'm a capitalist and you cut my taxes
why does that incentivize me to increase
the cost of my production right demand
increase it would you know encourage me
to hire more people yeah so I'm just
wondering if you could provide me with
like a steel man argument for
supply-side economics like why do we
even have like lower taxes for small
businesses in the first place right like
I would argue that it's you know small
businesses are less profitable and for
that reason we have maybe lower taxes
for the small man but yeah I think I
mean supply-side economics has been so
thoroughly debunked that it's hard for
me the only way I can steal man's
supply-side economics would be by
ignoring the facts and just repeating
the right wing talking point that
businesses create jobs and rich people
create businesses so therefore we should
make the economy as favorable to them as
possible so that they'll keep doing
their thing I mean it's just I feel like
an idiot saying it because it's been
demonstrated to just not be true I don't
have any kind of like unique way to prop
that argument up because that like
that's the argument they make and it's
not a very good argument yeah yeah for
sure do you think
smaller businesses like the ones you see
in your community do you think those
should have lower taxes well their taxes
those are mostly sole proprietorships
which are just taxed at the personal
rate so it's not I mean are you suggest
already I didn't even know that yeah so
the way a lot of the small businesses
operate there's a couple different ways
small businesses operate some really
small businesses you just go to the city
in which you operate in you say I want
to do business as it's called the DBA I
want to do business as you know David's
landscaping or whatever that means you
can accept checks at David David's
landscaping and then you file a Schedule
C on your tax return and it's just taxed
at the personal rate your business
expenses are deductible a lot of other
systems like s Corpse that are you know
oftentimes smaller businesses under 20
shareholders that's what's called
pass-through income LLC's are passed
through income it's all taxed at the
personal rate okay I didn't know that I
don't know yeah well right you know the
more you know the more empowered you are
to make decisions I appreciate the call
thank you
six one seven eight three zero forty
seven fifty we're taking calls we will
take a quick break and then take more
calls so if you're holding please don't
hang up
just a quick break and then I'll get
right back to the phone line